I know that whenever you cook sometimes
you're a fabulous cook she has I've gone
in her house she makes stuff and she
gives you one it's the most amazing
experience but one thing I found out
actually was the fact that when he cooks
sometimes right sometimes okay and he
has he's like very like perfectionist at
it right he's socially pretty good great
he's pretty good I wouldn't say
perfectionist he doesn't follow a recipe
he's pretty much like we'll throw things
together that maybe go together and then
he thinks it's fabulous and takes a
picture of it I call him Garth the
Stewart because Garth is Stewart very
pressed look look I made this sandwich I
could take a picture of it like that's
awesome honey yeah and you're like
meanwhile you're like look I'm a cooking
show and I'm badass but I'll be like
I'll be like can you open this jar of
pickles like well I have my own cooking
show I'm like really seriously I will
not stop talking until you subscribe to
my youtube channel that's right and I
could talk a lot seriously not gonna
stop yep still here not going anywhere I
see you don't walk away from this